To recap, over the course of this lesson we've discussed
a bunch of the basic skills required to do data wrangling
or data munching. So we've discussed some of the formats
that data might come in. Such as CSV, [UNKNOWN], and xml.
We've also talked about how to get this data from
a variety of sources. Such as SQL like databases, flat files,
and API's. We've also talked about how to look at the
data, see if things look all right, and if they don't,
some of the methods to mitigate these problems, such
as data imputation. Over the course of doing these
basic acquisition and cleaning tasks, you'll usually discover some
basic things about your data. But you might also want
to do some more sophisticated analysis to learn some
more subtle things about your data set. That's what
we'll learn in the next lesson, and then we'll
apply those insights to the New York City subway data.